EXCLUSIVE CONVERSATION WITH
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU EARLIER
TONIGHT.
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
>> MY PLEASURE.
WELCOME.
>> SO --
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
WAIT A MINUTE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU SOMETHING.
BEFORE I GO INTO THIS, YOU'RE
FROM PHILADELPHIA.
>> I AM FROM PHILADELPHIA.
>> I SPENT SOME YEARS IN
PHILADELPHIA.
>> I KNOW.
>> I DON'T WANT TO INTERVENE IN
YOUR FOOTBALL POLITICS I
UNDERSTAND THE EAGLES MADE IT TO
THE SUPER BOWL.
>> WE DID.
>> I OFFER YOU MY PERSONAL
CONGRATULATIONS.
ASK ME ANYTHING YOU WANT.
>> THANKS.
YOU'RE TRYING TO BUTTER ME UP A
LITTLE.
>> YES, OF COURSE I AM.
>> LET'S TURN TO A MORE SERIOUS
SUBJECT.
WE'RE SPEAKING AT A RATHER
PERILOUS TIME IT FEELS LIKE IN
THIS REGION RIGHT NOW.
ONE OF THE BLOODIEST MONTHS IN
ISRAEL IN THE REGION HAS SEEN IN
YEARS AND YEARS.
SEVEN ISRAELIS SHOT OUTSIDE A
SYNAGOGUE AT THE ENTRANCE OF A
SYNAGOGUE ON FRIDAY,
INTERNATIONAL HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY.
THAT WAS ONE DAY AFTER TEN
PALESTINIANS WERE KILLED AFTER A
RAID IN THE WEST BANK DURING A
RAID IN THE WEST BANK.
YOU PROMISED A STRONG AND SWIFT
RESPONSE TO THE SHOOTING OF THE
ISRAELIS.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU ABOUT
EVERYTHING JUST SPIRALING OUT OF
CONTROL, AS WE HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY SEEN HAPPEN IN THE
PAST?
>> LOOK, I THINK THERE'S ALWAYS
A DANGER OF THAT.
AND I DO EVERYTHING IN MY POWER
TO CONTAIN IT.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE LAST TEN
YEARS IN DURING WHICH I WAS
PRIME MINISTER WERE THE SAFEST
AND QUIETEST IN ISRAEL'S
HISTORY.
BUT PERIODICALLY WE HAD TO TAKE
SWIFT AND STRONG ACTION AGAINST
THE TERRORISTS.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN COLLECTIVE
PUNISHMENT, BUT I BELIEVE IN
FOCUSSED ACTION BOTH AGAINST THE
TERRORISTS THEMSELVES, THIS
ACTION THAT YOU REFER TO WAS
ACTION AGAINST INTELLIGENCE THAT
GAVE US A TICKING BOMB, A
TERRORIST OUTFIT THAT WAS OUT TO
MURDER ISRAELIS AND HAPPILY WE
KNOCKED THEM OUT.
UNFORTUNATELY ONE WOMAN WAS
KILLED IN THE CROSS FIRE.
>> A CIVILIAN.
BUT WHAT WE ENCOUNTERED IN LAST
TWO YEARS INCLUDING IN THE
OUTGOING GOVERNMENT WAS DOUBLING
OF TERRORIST ATTACKS FROM THE
PALESTINIANS BECAUSE THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY WAS NOT
REALLY EXERCISING ITS POWER TO
FIGHT THE TERRORISTS.
SO THE ISRAELI ARMY HAD TO COME
IN AND WE HAD TO COME IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS, TOO.
I'M TAKING TARGETED ACTION
AGAINST THE TERRORISTS.
THEIR IMMEDIATE CIRCLE OF
SUPPORTERS WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
HELPING THEM DO THE TERROR ACTS
OR CELEBRATED WITH FIREWORKS AND
THE CANDIES AND OTHER THINGS
THAT AFTER THE TERRORIST ACT.
WE THINK IF WE TAKE TARGETED
ACTION ON THE TERRORISTS AND
THEIR IMMEDIATE -- IMMEDIATE
CIRCLE, THIS CAN ACTUALLY LOWER
THE INCENTIVE FOR WHAT WE CALL
LONE TERRORISTS.
THEY'RE NOT LONE, THEY'RE WITHIN
A CONTEXT.
SO YOU WANT TO -- WANT TO TARGET
THEM BUT KEEP THE ECONOMY GOING,
KEEP 150,000 PALESTINIANS WORKS
IN ISRAEL, HAVEN'T CLOSE IT EVEN
IF R A MINUTE.
I DON'T INTEND TO.
>> SO RIGHT NOW EVERYONE IN THE
REGION, ESPECIALLY ALLIES, LIKE
SECRETARY OF STATE BLINKEN AND
OTHERS ARE CALLING FOR EVERYONE
TO BRING DOWN THE TEMPERATURE.
THE SECURITY COUNCIL OF ISRAEL
MET SATURDAY AND ANNOUNCED A
NUMBER OF MEASURES, INCLUDING
STRENGTHENING SETTLEMENTS, MORE
PUNISHMENT OF FAMILY MEMBERS OF
TERRORISTS, WHICH I THINK YOU
WERE ALLUDING TO A DEGREE THERE
AND OTHER MEASURES.
I'M WONDERING, DID SECRETARY
BLINKEN EXPRESS TO YOU WHETHER
HE THOUGHT THOSE MEASURES WOULD
ACTUALLY BRING THE TEMPERATURE
DOWN OR ACTUALLY EXACERBATE IT?
>> WELL, HE CERTAINLY SAID WHAT
I AGREE WITH WE SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
DEESCALATE, WHICH WE WILL.
IT'S NOT TARGETING FAMILY
MEMBERS.
IT'S TARGETING FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO WERE INVOLVED IN THE TERROR
ACTS OR SUPPORTED IT AFTER THE
ACT WAS DONE.
AND I THINK YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND, THESE TERRORISTS ARE
THEN CELEBRATED, ARE PAID BY THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY, THE MORE
THEY MURDER THE MORE THEY GET
PAID.
THE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO SUPPORTED
THE TERRORISM GET SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS AND OTHER
THINGS.
THAT'S WHAT WE TARGETED.
THAT DISINCENTIVIZES THE
TERRORISTS.
THEY WANT TO REALLY UPROOT US.
I SAID THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
UPROOT US.
WE'RE HERE TO STAY, INCLUDING IN
THE JEWISH COMMUNITIES AND
TERRITORIES THEY WANT TO UPROOT.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
I WANT TO DISENSENT VISE THEM.
MY RECORD IS ACTUALLY THE BEST
RECORD OF ANY ISRAELI PRIME
MINISTER OF ANY GOVERNMENT IN
CONTAINING IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE EASY.
BUT I THINK WITH -- I WOULD SAY
A JUDICIOUS USE OF FORCE AND THE
WILLINGNESS TO COOPERATE WITH
THE PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY AND
SECURITY MATTERS, I THINK WE CAN
CONTROL IT.
THAT'S MY HOPE.
I HOPE WE SUCCEED.
WE HAVE IN THE PAST.
WE SHOULD NOW.
>> SO YOU WERE JUST REFERRED TO
JEWISH COMMUNITIES IN THE WEST
BANK.
I KNOW THERE'S CONCERN IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND IN THE
WESTERN WORLD ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
I DON'T KNOW WHICH ONES
SPECIFICALLY YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
SOME ARE ILLEGAL AND THERE ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT EXPANDING SOME OF
THOSE SETTLEMENTS, ABOUT
ANNEXING LAND.
WHAT DID SECRETARY BLINKEN SAY
TO YOU ABOUT THAT?
BECAUSE MY IMPRESSION IS THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
CERTAINLY HE SAID THIS PUBLICLY
WHEN HE MET WITH YOU EARLIER IS
WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
AND WORRIED ABOUT THAT BRINGING
ISRAEL IN A PATH WHERE PEACE IS
NEVER GOING TO BE POSSIBLE.
>> WELL, I TOTALLY DISAGREE
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE FACT
THAT WE'RE HERE AND OUR
PEOPLE -- THE JEWISH PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN HERE FOR 3,500 YEARS, THE
FACT THAT JEWS LIVE HERE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE HERE AND
PALESTINIANS WILL CONTINUE TO
LIVE HERE AND WE HAVE TO LIVE
TOGETHER, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ETHNICALLY CLEANSE THE HEARTLAND
OF THE JEWISH PEOPLE AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO ETHNICALLY CLEANSE
ISRAEL.
20% OF ISRAEL'S POPULATION IS
ARABS.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SAY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE PEACE UNTIL WE
KICK OUT THE ARABS FROM ISRAEL
AND NOT GOING TO HAVE PEACE
UNTIL WE KICK OUT THE JEWSS FROM
THESE AREAS THAT ARE DISPUTED.
THEY'RE NOT ILLEGAL, DISPUTED.
THE ONLY WAY TO RESOLVE IS HAVE
PEACE NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
PALESTINIANS WHO CONSISTENTLY
REFUSE TO ENTER.
NOW I THINK WE CAN GET HUNG UP
ON THIS AND WE HAVE IN THE PAST.
PEOPLE SAID UNLESS YOU HAVE
PEACE WITH THE PALESTINIANS
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE BROADER
PEACE WITH THE ARAB WORLD.
25 YEARS THE PALESTINIANS WHO
DON'T WANT PEACE WITH ISRAEL
WANT TO SEE A PEACE WITHOUT
ISRAEL WHO DON'T WANT TO STAY
NEXT TO ISRAEL BUT A STATE
INSTEAD OF ISRAEL, THAT IN
EFFECT OF VETO ON ISRAEL'S
EXPANSION OF THE PEACE, CIRCLE
OF PEACE AROUND IT.
I WENT AROUND THEM.
I WENT DIRECTLY TO THE ARAB
STATES AND FORGED WITH A NEW
CONCEPT OF PEACE FOR PEACE,
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
I FORGED FOUR HISTORIC PEACE
AGREEMENTS.
>> THE ABRAHAM ACCORDS.
>> TWICE THE NUMBER OF PEACE
AGREEMENTS THAT ALL MY
PREDECESSORS IN 70 YEARS GOT
COMBINED.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT IT.
I KNOW YOU'RE COMMITTED TO THE
ABRAHAM ACCORDS WHICH ARE A HUGE
ACHIEVEMENT BY PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND BY YOU.
I KNOW YOU WANT TO KEEP GOING.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN LET'S SAY THE
BIG PRIZE IS -- I KNOW SUDAN IS
ON THE TABLE.
SOME OF THESE SOUTHEASTERN ASIAN
COUNTRIES ARE ON THE TABLE, BUT
THE BIG PRIZE IS SAUDI ARABIA.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN SAUDI ARABIA
GETS THE U.S. TO GO ALONG WITH
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
WANT FROM THE U.S. IN TERMS OF
SECURITY MEASURES, BUT THEY SAY,
LOOK, PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU,
THEY PROBABLY CALL YOU BIBI, I
NEED SOMETHING FOR THE
PALESTINIANS IN ORDER TO GO
ALONG WITH THIS.
I CAN'T DO THIS AROUND THE
PALESTINIANS.
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO ME AND TO MY
CONSTITUENCY.
WHAT ARE YOU WILLING TO GIVE?
ARE YOU WILLING TO LET PEOPLE IN
THE WEST BANK VOTE?
ARE YOU WILLING TO LET THE
300,000 ARABING WHO HAVE
RESIDENCY IN EAST JERUSALEM
VOTE?
>> WELL, I'M CERTAINLY WILLING
TO HAVE THEM HAVE ALL THE POWERS
THEY NEED TO GOVERN THEMSELVES.
BUT NONE OF THE POWERS THAT CAN
THREATEN US.
THIS MEANS THAT ISRAEL SHOULD
HAVE THE OVERRIDING SECURITY
RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE EVERY
TIME WE MOVED OUT, SAY FROM
LEBANON, BASICALLY IRAN CAME IN
WITH ITS PROXY HEZBOLLAH.
WE MOVED OUT OF GAZA, THE HAMAS
TOOK OVER.
IF WE JUST WALK AWAY, AS PEOPLE
SUGGEST, THEN YOU'LL HAVE HAMAS
AND IRAN MOVE INTO THE HILLS
AROUND JERUSALEM OVERLOOKING TEL
AVIV.
SO I THINK THERE'S A FORMULA FOR
PEACE.
BUT MY VIEW IS BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT THE CONTINUE YUM, THE
PERSISTENT PALESTINIAN REVIEW TO
REFUSE A JEWISH, THAT PERSISTS.
IF WE WAIT FOR THEM, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE PEACE.
PEOPLE SAID YOU HAVE TO WORK
YOUR WAY OUTSIDE IN.
FIRST, INSIDE OUT.
FIRST PEACE WITH THE
PALESTINIANS, PEACE WITH THE
ARAB WORLD.
I THINK REALISTICALLY IT HAS TO
BE THE ORE WAY AROUND.
WE MAKE PEACE WITH SAUDI ARABIA,
DEPENDS ON THE SAUDI LEADERSHIP.
AND BRING THE CONFLICT TO AN
END, I THINK WE'LL CIRCLE BACK
TO THE PALESTINIANS AND GET A
WORKABLE PEACE WITH THE
PALESTINIANS.
I THINK THAT'S POSSIBLE.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE WAY TO
GO.
>> IS IT A TWO-STATE SOLUTION?
>> WELL, I WOULDN'T CALL IT
NECESSARILY THAT BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THAT -- I HAD A DISCUSSION
WITH MY FRIEND OF 40 YEARS.
I'M NOT JUST SAYING FRIEND OF 40
YEARS, JOE BIDEN.
I MEAN THAT.
A PERSONAL FRIEND OF 40 YEARS
AND FRIEND OF ISRAEL.
A REAL CHAMPION OF ISRAEL.
AND I TOLD HIM, WHAT I JUST TOLD
YOU, I SAID, LOOK, ANY FINAL
AGREEMENT BETWEEN ISRAEL AND THE
PALESTINIANS WOULD HAVE ISRAEL
CONTROLLING SECURITY OVERRIDING
SECURITY RESPONSIBILITY IN THE
AREA WEST OF THE JORDAN, THAT IS
INCLUDES BOTH THE PALESTINIAN
AND JEWISH, ISRAELI AREAS THE
SIZE OF THE WASHINGTON BELTWAY,
THE WIDTH OF THE WASHINGTON
BELTWAY.
I SAID YOU CAN'T DIVIDE WHO
CONTROLS THE AIR SPACE.
YOU HAVE TO CROSS IT.
IT TAKES TWO MINUTES FOR AN
AIRLINE TO CROSS IT.
SO WHAT, ONE MINUTE ISRAEL
CONTROLS IT AND THE OTHER MINUTE
THE PALESTINIANS?
OF COURSE IT'S NOT WORKABLE.
HE SAID TO ME, AS OTHERS HAVE
SAID TO ME, YOU KNOW, BUT THAT'S
NOT PERFECT SOVEREIGNTY.
I SAID, YOU'RE RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU CALL IT,
BUT IT GIVES THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTROL THEIR
LIVES, TO ELECT THEIR OFFICIALS,
TO RUN THEIR ECONOMY, TO RUN
THEIR INSTITUTIONS, TO HAVE
THEIR FLAG AND HAVE THEIR
PARLIAMENT, BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
OVERRIDING SECURITY CONTROL.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE WAY WE'RE
GOING TO END UP, BUT I DON'T
THINK WE'RE GOING TO END UP NOW
BECAUSE THE PALESTINIANS REFUSE
TO NEGOTIATE A REAL PEACE AND
THE REASON -- THAT'S NOT BECAUSE
OF ME.
FOR MANY YEARS PEOPLE SAID I WAS
THE OBSTACLE TO PEACE.
WELL, I WAS REMOVED.
THEY HAD BARACK COME IN AS PRIME
MINISTER.
SHARONE AND ROBIN BEFORE ME.
NONE OF THEM SUCCEEDED BECAUSE
OF THIS PERSISTENT OBSTACLE.
SO I THINK THAT IF WE WANT TO GO
INTO A RABBIT'S HOLE AND TRY TO
RESOLVE THAT AND AVOID GOING TO
THE ARAB WORLD, I THINK WE
SHOULD GO TO THE ARAB WORLD.
I LEAVE MYSELF OPEN TO
NEGOTIATION WITH THE
PALESTINIANS AT ANY TIME.
BUT I THINK THAT THE WAY WE'RE
GOING TO SUCCEED IS NOT LET THE
PALESTINIAN TAIL WAG THE BODY OF
THE ARAB WORLD.
GET THE PEACE WITH THE ARAB
WORLD AND GET THE MORE REK